so hello and welcome to our broad
here for Monday evening the Monday
evening show with me this is really
really late and it was really weird
because you know to actually get such a
stream going you have to do a couple of
things technically and one of the
simpler things didn't work for some
reason or my experiment refused to work
and we had to really work it out because
it's like as as user unfriendly as you
can imagine so um I'm going to request
the five-minute game and I can already
tell you that there are a couple of
interesting opponents on we also have
mr. Wiggles here so we'll see what
happens okay so let's see that the
Cheetahs nicely positioned there I think
you've got the board yeah everything
looks good okay so I hope everything is
alright on your hand and you see and
hear me well yeah that wasn't the only
technical issue here so I've got the
game requested and hope to get pain
started we've got em Western so mr.
Weston what is he going to do 93 yeah go
see 5 and G 3 and this is not extremely
threatening to like but of course it's
very very solid what white is doing and
I have a couple of choices d6 or ecigs
think basically everything is fine so
I'm going to play for Bishop f3 getting
rid of the head of Bishop I've played
this line quite a number of times I
don't really think it turned out to be
all that successful I probably have to
probably have to check that again
sometime if I want to play it more often
yeah I got a good thing there in the
chat let's hope I don't get the adverse
stockfish yeah I did one of those
matches against stock pretty recently
and unsurprisingly got killed however I
was still a little bit surprised that
that I couldn't even score a single win
I mean I understand that I'm the the
underdog there but still okay um can I
get something going there it looks a bit
strange I kind of understand but but see
I can change check well Bishop takes
there is but there are a couple of
interesting things going here I think
you probably have to do this which is
not ideal admittedly I Scott Bishop f4
North 95 this is not a big deal n c3 n
so that's not an issue
an issue is however that c5 hangs and
would be seven wrong so I probably have
to move the Queen which is really not
nice actually for
frigging Queen a phone that didn't work
check and what a disaster
yeah it doesn't it doesn't work c5 hangs
everything hangs yeah this is just not
good yeah let's resign this planetary
side Wow okay that that really didn't
work at all
okay I think I have to get warmed up
it's kind of stressful to 30 minutes toy
around with some weird setup yeah I
don't know I have to get warmed up a
little bit
so I've got a game request out there are
actually quite a number sign it FM
doctorate Argo so let's see if I can
beat him getting dangerously low to
2,300 so we get a accelerated dragon it
seems that the full-fledged Roxy bond is
going to happen yeah I've had this on
the board forum I mean often really
really often a6m2 specially - yeah it
means if you send me some food for real
I mean I will eat it on the stream yeah
there was some talk about vice-versa and
stuff so I should have played b3 okay
not good yeah okay
yeah this is not idea that the this
opening is so solid that I still think
I'm okay c6 is reasonably weak I can go
b3 here I'm still quite okay down we're
going to see for a squeak yep is quick
clean on b5 makes some sense okay so I
cannot cancel it I can do this yeah
going for v6 after a for which you
prevented okay so let's do this yeah but
I can go before in this position right
if you take sit
I have Luke c8 and then we'll be with
Bishop h6 at the end so you cannot take
that pawn you can go a3 I'll just keep
it for the moment
and then c h5 okay all this is covered
threatening look-see aid I had started
real threats actually yeah it's for it's
not a real threats but maybe I can also
play book c7 I will see what he does
look a for well so after the check he
wants to move the King okay is that good
check okay so before is hanging okay
let's take this and now what to do
Queen b3 that's Queen d5 hmm yeah I
think I probably have to cover it simply
I clean trade like with rookie for
wouldn't be bad
look H for maybe that threatens on H 5
so we probably will take check and this
is the ending now is this really okay I
mean more than okay now you should
probably hold it somehow but I'm
threatening just b5 now
b5 look before and so on
it is not reacted not at all
now this is just winning forward I think
King up to a six or bring the look
around okay this actually traps my own
work so maybe not but this is also with
the tempo gain I can take a three for
the moment okay I just run the King out
that's impossible told ya
I need screw it up somehow I don't quite
know how exactly get to be honest it was
really a rather quick down for ya flex
flex game
so be seven and took a eight does the
trick
we don't need to do anything fancy I can
just take it black resigns this is that
was strange really after the Queen trade
white is better
pretty created better game started okay
no I tuned up or something I T no no hmm
okay maybe a transpose into abalone this
is an interesting opening here with this
is been only oh it doesn't want you so
this is a really really weird dragon do
you have to play I almost have to play
the six year for the real dragon right
if I go 96 that is not that's not an
accelerated dragon but the rear dragon
is also kinda weird so let's do this
maybe he doesn't know that Knight takes
c6 is good for wine now or at least
better for white meanie start with d4
Knight f3 zone maybe just Bishop e3 96 I
think I play DJ exam this is not really
very comfortable looking but I think it
sounds so terrible I've looked at this a
while ago because I was surprised that
some strong players actually allow this
and they normally played it like I do
now I know it looks terrible but they
somehow did not lose
if I can get any five yeah this is kind
of really kind of okay this is some
looking a little bit like the philidor's
defense so Bishop c5 and this 85 okay
I'm doing this 97 I can trade the dogs
with bishops and play the King up to
several I think M it should be okay he
can castle long though I think actually
looked you one is better long castling
maybe Bishop c5 is somewhat reasonable
maybe maybe
yeah this is stronger yeah because after
Bishop c5 there's route 67 yeah okay so
I have to do it differently maybe this
this first intending Bishop e6
it's not not exactly comfortable but
maybe it's okay I was a really strange
move water I wonder how often this is
coming yeah so I retired I had really
really long and yeah stressful weekend
playing which was not the biggest part
but organizing our town championships it
was a nicer and a really really good
event okay see if I can provoke him to
play C 3 so that after C 3 Bishop c5 and
I Knight coming to c5 b 3 is actually
hanging so for interesting
I play the draw in the second round of
the tournament as I tend to do quite
often
okay b5 b5 it's not what the doctor
ordered but C fourth I don't want to
allow a 9 to 0 so maybe I actually
Bishop c3 was a move let's move it let's
play it so this isn't bad you know 90 48
this one maybe
it depends my opponent was rated roughly
2000 when I played the draw and but it
really depends this is really displaying
the level roughly two thousand is a wide
range you sometimes get people who are
really pretty reasonable in the case of
this person I've already considered a
draw against him in an earlier event
this is a funny position by the way
because yeah the 92 I could actually I
could capture it was hey check checking
[Music]
yeah I can double him cannot take on a
five I mean maybe you can at night xp3
should be good we cannot move at night
I'm also a four maybe I'll just keep
them keeping back
[Music]
okay just keep things for the moment
aha
so it probably wants to play and take
like this maybe this is putting more
pressure on white even though it's not
clear what I know this is not good see
quite resigned yeah I got got some some
suppression why I'm not viola playing in
the German championship um well it's not
a very attractive tournament announced
the main thing is you cannot just play
games star you have to qualify and then
you have to start at a reasonably low
level so I'm it means just not like the
one week of the German championships but
you have to play in the regional
championship the state championships and
so on so you have to really fight your
way up to their tournament and for a
tournament at the end that you can get
by joining any decent open event
it just isn't just not a justification
to to waste all that time no the the
northern Australian championship isn't
very strong people's just don't play
good stronger people and I'm not really
all that interested in it I mean I've
won it almost 20 years ago and like once
this is enough yeah black is okay here
mr. Chekov shake her off I've played a
really somewhat uninspiring
set up against this virgos in
let's go for before you might be able to
play b5 here could be reasonable levy
form so probably not why have you for
that's good for wide
yeah North rhine-westphalia should have
a strong state championship
theoretically speaking there are many
good players but it is just not such an
attractive event I mean it's perfectly
okay to play but it's something that is
for me not not really all that
interesting
yeah this is hanging
yeah let's do this rooftop good night f6
galaxy s German Championships is
reasonably strong absolutely my first
chest book and that's tough to say
actually I think very likely it was some
book some pretty heavy told about chests
that kind of which included a bit of
everything I think it was written by T
Oh shoes I think German players probably
know it or know him near Shuster it's
pretty well-known author just for Tigers
is actually really good if you have that
it's a good one yeah yeah I play with
2151 the German and then a north of a
same temperature I can assure you that I
know this guy I've played them before
and I know I know that 2150 doesn't
sound like much and he also has this
weak moments but he also well outplayed
me in that games the beg lend and yeah
there are people who are capable of
playing really good chance once in a
while
I'm Tony Antonio Guterres wants my
opinion on the controversy between
Magnus Carlton and with Ashley as I read
on Facebook they kind of had a talk and
everything is fine again
so there are nothing there's no big I
know what the right word is no real
avoid coming out of it or something yeah
I'm not so happy with this move but I
don't quite know how to play against the
knight in the long run it just doesn't
look very very attractive this position
um about the incident as a whole I think
I think that Magnus could have reacted a
little bit nicer but I understand the
point really because I mean this is this
reminded me and it's someone somebody
actually posted that on reddit this
comparison and that there was the same
interview against after that in the 2014
soccer world championships when they
asked one of the German defenders
Parramatta soccer I come after the match
chance I think it was was it Algeria or
was it Morocco
I'm sorry but it was some I think one of
one of those only things in the Indyk in
the round of the last 16 when he was
asked why Germany's play was crap or
what not yeah and Jim Leatrice wonders
and was really tough match and this was
the famous interview where meta soccer
was really frustrated and it became
really famous famous the ice phone
interview it's hard to translate but he
was mostly at the end he was just
stating you know I add okay I'm just
going to liner you know
yeah in a big container of ice on three
days and then we're going to talk about
it again
chairs really funny okay so I think I
have to make a chain which is kind of
okay thank you can also draw drum after
all really a crap game okay let's get to
request the new one yes I wrote Algeria
and it's it's something I really find it
inappropriate yeah you have the world
champion scoring almost almost three
thousand performance and record and you
start like I you know why didn't you
have a smooth performance this is just
crap I mean I mean I'm roughly maurice's
playing strength and I would never ever
think of this kind of question really if
I'm just there reading out engine
evaluations and not much more
so this is just nonsense to me okay
playing I am pet basement and somehow I
got into the Benoni yeah that was a
question about Vincent Kaymer the German
prodigy if I think that he can become a
world champion to be honest I have no
idea simply because I've never never
really studied his games the results of
course that he has are excellent so he
must be very talented but I have never
really looked at the games and this is
some kind of it depends sometimes a
little bit on how the games look I mean
I definitely do remember seeing Magnus
play for the first time like in the
limelight and in 2003 when he was
playing was it 2004 I think it was 2003
when he was playing why can they see GU
and
and it was extremely obvious that this
is going to be a world championship
contender so what to do here got some
funky tactics maybe just nod you fall I
don't know if he I mean see three hangs
and do you really want to take on e4 I
don't know if he wants what he does it
probably has to take the six otherwise
capturing only four didn't doesn't make
much sense okay so does it interesting
but so what does you want to do go f3
and then
what about this for Queen 85
um okay maybe just screech f6 or
something and many many things
deikun does
I mean I'm reasonably happy this must be
a good position once before the screen
b2 so he just lets me take it right when
Weiss what's the issue I take it quite
resigned yeah there was a nice display
of the modern benoni in action sometimes
it works oh there was a pretty smooth
win against I am Pat Bateman I think it
was reasonably smooth
okay I've got a new game request out and
they have to disappoint you that Oleg
ass is not on anymore
I know you're kind of rooting for this
match to happen with okay yeah there are
these things like yeah you should have 0
to 650 at age 16 yeah I don't know I
don't think this is necessarily true I
don't think this is necessarily true I
mean look at Aronian he's a daily of
cyanate world-class player and I think
he at age 16 he was nowhere near that to
650 M II was a good gem but not as high
rated as to 650
I wonder if a night move might be
possible can I teach five or something
weird that is it
maybe yeah of course I mean in Germany
becoming a chest professional or
something that is a tough decision to
make and now we place that crap I mean
it's not crappy just crap that we looked
at that's what I try to say hmm
yeah I completely screwed this up I mean
completely now and this is extremely
easy to play also not good
yeah
Bishop a5 is not exactly subtle but it
could work okay so he wants to sacrifice
in a more fanciful way so I figured of
course this extremely unnecessary the
sacrifice but you can probably do it
again like if black has a pawn already
but it's clearly not the best move
25 or something are okay Queen a for I
should at the end wind important
material
I think the FB 7 should drop and with it
okay didn't spot this would be 75 idea
and now my looks really do a decent job
lack regularity Siobhan g7 totally sucks
yeah it was extremely unnecessary I'm I
was completely outplayed in the opening
and okay next one yeah again in in in a
western country it's a bit difficulty I
becoming a chess professional especially
becoming a chess professional game you
start it when you don't have anything as
a backup yeah I mean they're just like
drop out of school and play chess if the
kind of the tough to see and that would
only really advice to do that to someone
can really really really really really
get very far and this is a very
difficult judgment to make the thing is
I live this this person absolutely
absolutely wants to do it and has the
total desire to become extremely strong
players and it is an interesting thing
to do I mean at the end yeah you should
do where you have the the most you have
the most desire where you value burned
most in a way are to be successful and
if it is playing chess it's probably not
such a bad idea to try it I mean okay
well this is not very interesting how do
I play this actually I've had some game
with this I still don't like it
I mean I actually actually do like it in
the sense that I think like it's okay
but it's not it's not something where I
have we have a clear idea yeah I think
Demetri call us is one of the rare on
cases where somebody at a really early
age relatively early age decided to
become a chess professional in Germany
and I don't know how it's doing everyday
I mean you just I think he has completed
his GM norms and so I didn't really mean
him speak specifically it's just that
it's it's certainly one of those cases
where you think okay yeah I mean he
doesn't seem to be strong enough to do
it in some way but I mean if he really
wants to try why not I mean why not I
don't think if you try for like I'd say
two or three years and if you find out
okay that wasn't for me you can still go
to the University or whatever yeah I
mean it's possible but everybody's
personal situation is different for sure
I mean sometimes they have backup where
parents or awesome you just don't know
or any all of the details okay put the
bishop here
[ __ ] my bishop on d5 if I get my
bishop on to d5 I'm extremely happy I
wonder if he should play some 95 stuff
yes so yeah I wonder let's just look c8
keep it simple
yeah his queen has very little space I
mean I can definitely do this it might
in there some way to friggin truck that
Queen yeah this looks nice but I have to
check white resides yam be out studied
mathematics I don't know if he finished
what he did yeah a tough game eeeh
against by important but game
outstanding I got a decent position out
of it
okay playing Hoffman good white a
hundred off one I think said true yeah
good on maestro okay so bad no a yes and
I wanted to play jeez three what about a
banker with age six extra I don't know
probably isn't really good yeah
now I figure whiskers up to enter which
level do I train tactics and start
reading a book
we can always rate the chess book
there's nothing wrong with it I mean the
usual recommendation is to rely heavily
on tactics and only then go for openings
and so on I don't think that you have to
do something like tactics exclusively
yeah for the whole fall for the whole
beginning period that's really not
necessary but I think it should be the
focus but you can always start to to
look at other things and look at endings
look at some openings it's unpopular to
advice beginning players to to check
openings but I do think it makes some
sense up to a certain degree yeah it
doesn't make sense if you look at 20
moves of mainline dragon theory that
that makes no sense but for white and
black to know the first couple of moves
four three four or five moves know what
let's say then what the Italian game is
all know that if you are faced with one
deform that you play d5 or that you play
like a queen's gambit declined it's just
an example yeah you don't have to play
the Queens gambit declined and I think
this makes perfect sense to have some
rough outline of in repertoire and then
go with it and then if you if you know
like you played the Italian game with d3
for example then you know what games to
look to look at them and understand the
underlying ideas better yeah so here I
have a Benko style position and I think
that should be quite a reasonable
version and
okay so I agree here yeah the addictive
queen is actually covered I wonder if I
should just play Bishop piece have now
even though yeah why not actually
because you can take a data was stupid
it just takes it okay it's not a big
problem this is for example I think it's
perfectly okay because I will get the a
pawn and then I have a pretty good
position actually reform for the moment
and now I can take you five which I will
do how I said actually the best we've
been probably not on yeah but it's okay
how to do this I can take here yeah it's
not really great chatting let's chicken
and now I should not blunder the night
iam really not
yeah this is not not-so-nice now family
he has a hard time with the bishop the
bishop and the pawn that's really really
tough for him to defend black resigns
yeah they didn't play this this really
well to defend against this um I think
you won't hear black must be okay but
somehow I got enough play it's always
started difficult to handle this
initiative okay living black against
Farhan he does not have anything no
title attached yeah I would play
differently now
yeah to a triela death really it looks a
little bit like yeah I tried to make fun
out of him it was really just about slip
I wanted to play g3
huh that look strange
maybe this is all so strange but okay
okay so what now
both captures look reasonable this is a
bit more active in terms of pieces so
I'm going to do this I wanted to go 93
and stuff yeah like my camera as under
promotion against Normandy our offices
it is says I mean I think it it is funny
and it's really funny
and it does have some some people wrote
like oh my god he's I don't know um yeah
I don't know like he he wants to just
make fun of his opponent or not this is
just nonsense of it it's just that he
really believes it doesn't make a
difference and I think then it's it's
just a funny thing to play the under
promotion and as it turned out it made a
pretty big difference I mean it was
still a draw actually welcome yeah it
has to be had to be said to be really
proved proven proven it is a draw if he
just promotes he'll clean it it's very
obvious okay
and pretty easy draw he just thought it
doesn't matter at all and then went for
it isn't that working this is actually I
played this a cat quickly the night only
to doesn't really have all that many
squares again I can always probably yeah
check my light has no squares
I wonder actually 98 see three that that
could be a move I'm threatening EVD for
quite quite badly
this should be 5s in Bishop f1 and they
have deform
okay I'm going deform maybe night takes
you three words so I didn't trust us
just takes this again 92 is a pretty big
threat yeah okay um
and move the night a semanas hanging
bishop c6 is relatively simple and good
which doesn't really inspire nor look at
my ass asking a question i don't know
him in person
I mean I've played enough tournaments in
Berlin in the mid nineties to note to
know the person but I've never played
him more and any sort of real contact
okay so [ __ ] was hanging and III Isola
pain letter Jack's on anyway with a
seven was a check which be six prevented
okay so I can take B to now don't see a
real drawback
[Music]
the bishop is singing actually so I
should cover it took me a while I'm not
sure this was really good I think it
will be difficult to win anyway maybe
you can just take Claire loopy 7 I'm a
bit ahead on the clock which is good and
why does not do anything good
ok 95 496 cool absolutely ok I have
night h4 check go check
check I do have anything better yeah I
don't see a check okay so I can just
take care of course I do have something
better check I don't see it so I'll take
it and now I can check him or do I have
something better Bishop here is also
possible but the bishop is hanging so
it's not that easy time morning okay
let's just let's probably just take this
and it's just one cornea I actually
thought it was more I just did a
marvelous miscount for them two points
up
oh I makes you too fond of it great
great counting with the international
master sometimes successfully oh not so
nice I had to check out did I have the
check check
come on and he went into a self pen
blank forfeits on time I guess you can
do it forever
okay so I somehow won this game fighting
my way all through it so I think I
haven't really good run here and for no
particular reason I'm winning a lot yeah
I lost the rain this game turning up to
that started to really score so let's
see what aaron is up to age three again
no I don't think I don't think so
yeah to watch salvation shock true games
you'll again see to Qaeda which means
what chess club do you guys are that's
easy
I'm member of my chess club should fine
indeed flocking my local club my
hometown club the club where I started
to play and actually nowadays I'm also
the president of that club so you kind
of clear that out also with it that
regularly so yeah this is um interesting
it's a little bit like does some reverse
guru felt tendency the policy six is my
my target in this position
I don't know Queeny Queeny for yeah
let's do it let's just take it first and
ask questions later
so let's control pH and prepare look-see
one
yeah president of the chess club that
sounds pretty I don't know it sounds a
little bit much in German lingua Terra
sound as pompous I think if this is a
word I think we just have select
chairman and chairman is probably
actually better than president yeah
president sounds really weird
no but Donald Trump fish no chairman is
probably the right word
okay um and I'm thinking about if I hear
I don't know it's really good though so
I'm just getting everything into play a
seven is somewhat attacked would before
you
guys got the form on the cards the p3
looks really strange really strange
I have a bad feeling about this why not
to move the F rope I cannot tell you and
it's not one of those I cannot tell you
I can't tell you but then I have to kill
you I really don't know sometimes the
Blitz you just decide that intuitively I
didn't quite know what the Abel would do
probably okay look before I take a seven
that was my plan and this is just crap
you know because it can go deform so
well maybe I can play a three after
deform very strange but he should go
look before that is the most principled
move here by farm I mean you can
probably play a loop you aide or
something like that nothing wrong with
that
yeah so I'm running this after d4 I can
take nine takes a three maybe it works
maybe it is very weird though after will
be seven on a 24 35 I can go back to a
form basically repeating and now Queen
a7 look b7 is there a waiter I can
actually go to a 6d for Bishop takes d4
sb7 is still hanging
okay um what's now McQueen is really a
little bit too off
the point of hanging I mean a half night
a four maybe it look strange oh really
and I thought I didn't expect I thought
you would take
and like rooks I can just take this six
next move so I want the two points for
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
black resigns okay so that was the final
game I think for the team I don't even
know we started really late when I think
we have been on for a solid hour yeah
okay guys I'm happy that you decided to
wait for bits because the stream style
was heavily delayed and very happy that
you stayed on I think it was a really
good session yeah I've gained close to
100 points and played some I think
entertaining games I hope you enjoyed it
I'll be back next Monday I think not
sure there shouldn't be any reason why
not to so next Monday hopefully yeah on
time
yeah thanks for watching bye bye
you